i'm here because um this is going
totally wrong it is a show and the whole
nation media is calling it a show it's
racist it's biased there should be a
mistrial without our voices i just feel
like we need to show them that we're not
playing and we're here
and we are listening we're watching
and yeah i'm here to stand up for what's
right and i believe that he should do
time for what he did i'm here
to support the calls for kyle to go to
prison for a very long time we've seen
them out there that night we've seen all
the militia on the roof pointing their
lasers at everybody people walking
through our parking lot pointing lasers
at them
they were he was as far as i'm concerned
he was there to show off so he could get
on social media holding an ar-15
and brag to his friends he had no clue
he was a scared little kid that should
have not been here
period injustice anywhere
is injustice everywhere what he did was
horrible and there's people out here
saying that you know self-defense isn't
a crime but it's like me
breaking into somebody's house
and them coming at me and i shoot them
and kill them because they were going to
kill me for being in their home and
robbing them and that's how i kind of
feel like this is like and i don't like
that i will be protesting
i will stand in solidarity with anyone
who wants to protest if kyle rittenhouse
is not found guilty of uh murder
um but i will also be protesting an
injustice a system of injustice a system
of oppression a system built by white
supremacists
um if kyle is found guilty because if
kyle is found guilty of murder uh there
is still a lot of injustice going on i
mean the very fact that this judge can
continue to be on this case is an
injustice